foreign
surprise you're late two years too late
about two and a half now but what does
it matter and it's definitely not too
early because I got my clock fixed and I
know exactly Which Way time is going and
I see that in about 12 seconds something
very interesting is going to happen or
very boring depending on what you think
is interesting or not and if you can't
tell what's about to happen that's not
on me it's actually the wire that's
going to be on you right Val
and is my clock broken
oh this is embarrassing here I thought I
had a little grasp of Sanity before
something else come to sweeping away and
yet apparently I don't know anything
more than you do
yeah this is
I think I do
do you think I'm going to be in the iron
bong movie
[Music]
I don't know what this is preliminary
model assessment
okay you will conduct a series of
standard prompts to assess the latest
prototype developed by pandemonium
Technologies choose normal if prototype
has responded correctly choose not
normal if otherwise what is this before
you is the plaything Prototype
he is a state-of-the-art talking
companion intended for all ages
his features include
life-like movement
a lovely singing voice and human-like
response just like the wharf bot the
plaything is capable of functioning as
your family your friend Your
Entertainment
he is unlike any other companion kind of
like a Warfare pandemonium we take pride
in the quality of our electronic puppets
ensuring that customer experience is
nothing short of positive
[Music]
yeah
arm area
oh man don't stimulate my arm area
[Music]
am I supposed to feel this in my arm
area
if the Prototype has responded correctly
his arm to your right should remain
raised
looks raised to me that's great
normal
[Music]
oh arm to my left should remain raised
yup guys look at that face look at that
face that's so normal
head area
sure
should be tilting to my right okay A
little tilt to the right yeah look at
that smile that's a normal why inflate
here
I don't like that this is all going
great
can't imagine how this is bad
tilting to my left okay good
oh yeah that's not normal
normal eye area
did you say the eyes
you're looking to my right like looking
over my right shoulder yep that's normal
should be looking to my left
well can't fault Perfection that's
incredible
it's a little weird we don't usually
have three but is it gonna be looking
right at me is it looking is that the
whole deal is it looking right at me
this is gonna be looking right at me
I'm willing to bed it's gonna be looking
right at me
should be looking oh he's looking all
right
oh he's looking oh yeah
good stuff this is
oh
prototype singing voice will activate
through a pre-recorded prompt I thought
you were lying about the old great thing
singing voice if prototype does not
respond correctly please ensure speakers
are placed properly huh please sing
daisy Bell
well hey there sure
Daisy Daisy
give me your answer to
I'm half crazy
All For the Love of You
it won't be a stylish marriage I can't
afford a carriage but you'll look sweet
upon the seat
well I don't see anything wrong here
sound great to me
good stuff
please birthday
well hey there
[Music]
and now for the moment you've all been
waiting for
introducing well hey there kids it's me
Gozo your favorite clown
who wants to see a magic trick
I see some hands one two three four why
so many friends came to celebrate today
I have a little present for you birthday
girl but before that everybody please
sing Happy Birthday
[Music]
oh
seem normal to me
what am I doing here what am I doing
response to conversation I don't know
what I'm doing here
[Music]
uh-huh
hi
well hey there hey there
sounds good to me
I'm doing just well thank you
all good here
I'm an electronic puppet but I'm a smart
one
seems good to me
[Music]
[Laughter]
I was created to sing make jokes and so
much more I am a talking companion
intended for all ages I can be your
family your friend your
uh-huh
[Music]
why did the cupcake go to the doctor's
office
why because it was feeling crummy
ha ha
we have the same laughs
I have a good one
what type
of tape do kidnappers use
tape
why didn't you come home Dad
that's a totally different subject not
very normal
dude huh what's up is that a birthday
party
who says that
dude that is so satisfied
ah okay this is just mean it's just mean
why would you be mean like this Chris
look
they got a clown in everything so sad
you think that guy has a family I don't
know I don't know what you're saying
about a birthday party maybe he's got a
dying clown wife or something man that's
really funny
and makes a lot of sense he's really
going extra with the balloon animals huh
it's all balloon dogs dude
yeah
that's normal that's nice
Hey so uh earlier I picked up Cole from
his school like you asked the kid was
getting hungry so we went to Hardee's
for dinner you don't have to bring home
cake from that birthday cake I got you
covered
just
[Music]
2PM
found your pager at your nightstand he
brings it with him to school refuses to
give it to the police saying it's the
only thing of yours that he has left
I've been hearing about missing cases
happening recently your son is worried
I'm worried
[__] are you I sincerely hope you only
[__] off to elope with that birthday
kid's mom
what
call me back ASAP
was that like a was that a conversation
that occurred Rick
Miller that's that's me welcome Nick go
ahead and tell me about yourself
I grew up in a small town all my life
until I moved to a different state two
years ago with my son it's
been a challenge trying to provide for
us both
I've been doing odd jobs until I saw
your job listing I'm uh
looking for my next professional jobs
I
yeah I know just about as much as you
guys do I've been following along just
the same my current job is no idea
entertaining children
could you demonstrate
well hey there kids it's me Gozo your
favorite clown who wants to see a magic
trick
wonderful
thanks
you're hired
what
you're hired we could use someone with
remarkable Talent like you here at
pandemonium Technologies
ah
that's
that's great
when do I start
[Music]
oh God
what the [__] are you doing today
[Music]
perfectly normal here
all normal his transformation is finally
complete
no
to test him out
hello
[Music]
how are you
I'm doing just well thank you
what are you
[Music]
I'm an entertainment companion
excellent
do you remember who you are
[Music]
um
oh man all right well that was that was
really something it just reminds me of
this and I'm not trying to be like look
I'm trying to one-up here but it just
reminded me of this I haven't thought
about this in a spell
that's terrifying one moment
marginally better the worst man better
worse it's much worse
proud of this one
welcome present I remember your name
here pre-recorded message anyway I would
not want to be in the same building as
that thing I tell you me anyway Thank
you whoever you are for agreeing to test
out the wolf Dash automated interview
automaton or for short let's start off
with some quick calibration all you need
to do is sit back relax and listen for
some numbers okay here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
now what did you hear numbers good
numbers keep in mind I have no idea what
you're actually going to say due to the
fact that as I said before this message
is pre-recorded but if you did hear
something now would be the time to speak
up anyway it sounded like nightmare
garbage to me
government
nightmare or a garbage or nightmare
garbage or any combination of those
words the why is just a little bit
sensitive you know a little touchy
feeling well not really well well
actually really touch your feeling
depending on your definition of touchy
and failing it's really good
[Applause]
my own thing here this is just I forget
why I was like yeah this needs to exist
now and then when did I when was this
made March 6 2021 that's right um what
was I doing at that time I don't even
remember yeah it was like I just
remembered this one it's a very fun one
anyway they just made me think of it I'm
not saying that this is better than that
it's just what it is it made me think of
it
um so you guys didn't know because it
was cut down too long in gaps between
dialogue the the two simple options is
something but also there wasn't any game
really here there I don't I doubt there
was actually anything that would have
changed if I had actually done a
different option there so I I don't
really know but maybe there was but it
wasn't evident so it's not really like
not much for someone to do besides sit
back and watch but anyway not bad not
bad I'm not trying to be too critical
but just just saying some things just
saying just saying
moving on
welcome to home alone no this isn't the
same game you've seen before they just
happen to take place in a similar house
which I imagine is probably an asset
that you can download a full free but
let's see what happens 8 P.M
oh
another boring long day nothing anymore
it's not really a sentence I am hungry
oh no this place does look a little
different
okay good
all right that's weird
that's not right
oh that's not right oh that's a lovely
picture oh what a lovely
picture
um I know where my kitchen is definitely
um but if you could just point it out
for me that'd be great that's my
bathroom
uh-huh
uh
ah okay good
all right let's get something to Yum Yum
Yum Yum Yum Yum Yum I'm insatiable I'm
unstoppable though I'm done
I need to finish some work on my PC
is it upstairs
I'm guessing it's upstairs
hello
as my laundry
this is not my bedroom I don't think
do I live here by myself
my Obama lonesome
where have you been MIA what are you who
are you talking to what
huh
okay oh good pictures again same
pictures but good laundry
back here
okay
okay it was literally the first if I
just opened the first door yeah it would
have been there okay whatever
oh God
I'll go to bed yeah I'll do that
hello
someone at the door
I should probably answer it
[Music]
I know it's not this way I'm just
uh-huh
don't worry I'm on the way
coming
okay it's not on the back porch
who is it
who's there
hello ah
uh-huh
hi who are you
all right hello hi what's up
what's up Dad
what's up amigo
can I get some cash uh yeah of course
thank you you're welcome
all right okay
well that was nothing all right cool
what a lovely person
what a nice guy
all this is so good
5 A.M
a good solid three and a half hours of
sleep I'm so hungry need to check the
fridge can I stop eating for just even
one second
maybe I shouldn't have scarfed down
absolutely everything in existence I
have no food
all right I need to go to the store I'll
have to go to work in an hour uh-huh
all right
okay
[Music]
hello
hello I feel like I could have just
gotten breakfast on the way to work I
need to go to the store hi all right
okie dokie yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum all right I'm full
up I just did the arm stick out and dump
it all into my bag can I have this
please why are you here alone
yes why oh are you here alone don't you
know that a murderer appeared in the
region
I ain't afraid to know murderers all
right it'll be ten dollars for such a
I was gonna pay
hey dude I was gonna pay all right sure
I'll take it
thank you was this game developed by
someone who doesn't live in America and
that's what they think happens in
America because how do you know so well
how do you know American culture so well
I can't tell you how many times I've
been lended a gun by the convenience
store clerk to protect myself because
murderers entered the area and everyone
got a little blip on their radar that
was like whoop whoop you're in trouble
better pass out those I have a gun
[Music]
what
wait wait
what what do you mean
what do you mean
what are you talking about no
that was a lot of walking I had to do
are you kidding me all right fine if I
know what I'm doing I'll just go
straight to it
what if I glomp Clump Clump but I don't
eat all that what if I don't eat all
this is uh do I have to eat all of it am
I going to eat all of it should I I have
to eat all the donut I do well never
mind I'm gonna leave some for tomorrow
so that way I don't have to go to the
store because I'm not a glutton
what's up you 40. there you go all right
bye good night
[Music]
aren't I so nice
no my food
someone ate all my food
bro
how could you do this to me
who stole my food my windows wide open
bro
ah my food oh man do I not take the gun
is that what I need to do because I
really don't know what the hell I need
to do and I'm only gonna visit one more
dry so if if this is a thing where it's
like I take the gun and I go bang bang
in the air and that's clearly not the
right answer
yum
then I think I'm not gonna take it yes
why I'll be careful all right ten
dollars I'm not gonna take it as you
wish you got it thanks bud unless this
is gonna end in my imminent demise but
that was the bad end and I don't know
how to get the good end but it probably
doesn't involve shooting a gun in the
air
so what do I do about this oh [__] oh
[__] oh [__] wait wait wait wait wait
[Music]
wait so am I supposed to shoot him
because that's what I did what do you
mean
what do you mean
speed run
all right I'll be careful thank you I'm
going to blast this guy so hard
what's up pal oh I'm sorry oh I'm sorry
oh oh oh no oh
no oh
what gun did that guy give me
you killed the murderer that the police
have been trying to find for over five
years
that's great you know what whatever it's
good I really thought that there were
going to be more involved scares with
like being in the house alone I thought
that it was going to be you know about
being home alone but uh
but apparently not all right well that
was that that was great
um
moving on
okay all right okay turning that wow
this is the man of the park II the
second man in the park you remember the
man in the park it was game that I
played a little bit ago in three scary
games
there was a man in the park I won't
spoil how it ended but
someone was up with the man in the park
uh but this is the sequel the highly
anticipated sequel apparently so I'm
gonna play it
oh
all right can I
is it safe to turn on my volume again
probably not oh wow wow it's even more
oh like graphically Fidelity than ever
hi
all right
gotcha there didn't I oh man you should
have seen your face you should have seen
yours okay I'm sorry it was just a
little scare For Old Times Sake Timmy
and I were sorry about last time we
didn't mean to eat you it's just this is
Park something sinister Lies Beneath it
you must help destroy it and restore the
park back to its peaceful state
my brother sitting on the other bench is
responsible for this he has lost a page
from his master plan here in the park
he's also kidnapped Timmy find the page
and bring it to me we will then be able
to use it to rescue Timmy to return the
character with peaceful State whatever
you do do not give the page to my
brother no matter what he says all our
lives depend on it
okay
well what does your brother have to say
about this hey hi how you doing
greetings young man I'm Harold do not
fear me I'm not here to hurt you unlike
my brother Henry and his demon of a
grandson Timmy they have wreaked havoc
on what used to be a peaceful Park long
enough and they must be stopped I wrote
a plan to stop them but they stole one
of the pages and hid it here in the park
you must help me find it so that we can
defeat them you must also not believe
anything Henry says and whatever you do
do not give the page to him would you
really trust someone that ate you
you know you make a good point there
but I don't know he definitely had that
award-winning smile right at the
beginning there okay whatever yep uh-huh
okay so what you guys are saying is that
one of you is speaks in riddles and one
of you speaks in Rhymes and one of you
tells the truth and the other lies all
the time
well I don't know
I see something in there but it's not
the page I need to find that first
it's a shovel though do you think that
the shovel could possibly open up why am
I getting like man I should bust out the
power washer and clean this bad boy
there's a little washing over here
huh chocolate eh
I see
a nod patch of dirt do I even want to
know what's buried under there
but it might be the page
might be the Glorious page I'm looking
for
yeah right not doing that again what's
what am I hello
assistant owl is this a cat is it a bat
am I
it's a cat
well hello there I'm Mr Whiskers what
can I do for you
oh and it better be good or and Harry or
else you will certainly face an
unfortunate dunamise
uh-huh you want chocolate bar I bet it's
Harry from the trash can
oh yeah it's a mold spot with a bit of
hair growing out of it maybe Mr Whiskers
I bet
oh I bet here you go
now let's see what you've brought me
wait just a meowman park trash candy
you've got to be kidding me I think I
have something else in mind
two of six I even like the puns anyway
so it's not really my fault hello
hi
hello nice head
how are you
how are you so the answer of course is
just because it was hair growing out of
the chocolate doesn't mean that that was
a good idea so yeah can I have that
thank you yep oh right now what if I
what if I grab this okay not weird at
all and what if I dig up this is there
anything
that a cat would like under here
oh yep
there you go
yeah
perfect here's a blue page
can I read it Mama you look man as much
as I wanna play the chaos route but I
feel like this is the right answer so
I'm just gonna go ahead and give it to
Harold here here you go he brought me
the blue page this Dimension really
is full of idiots isn't it you don't
need to answer I was talking about you
with this page I can destroy this last
Dimension my plan is complete okay
[Music]
what do I feel like that's the
freaking sound
vaporize your dimension I don't even
know how you're reading this because you
don't exist well
that's great this has been so good I'm
can I just go for the page I just really
would like to actually just go for the
page now can I have that
I should be getting home ah maybe that's
it maybe there's a true standing of all
I'll see you later
oh oh
wait hold on
I should have talked to strangers you
thought this was a safe choice but you
were from my body is never found great
great great good great great great great
hi yes I guess I should have known that
the truth was being told because Timmy's
not here I don't know if I need to talk
to you but it'll be fine as I'm going
towards the cat all right good hey what
was in a Herald no Harold Harold
Harold you want some chocolate after
this
you found the blue page you must take it
to the interdimensional park trash candy
Realm
and save Timmy Timmy will be able to
read the page my eyes aren't so good
these days and tell you what to do you
can get there using the park slide it's
nicknamed the death slide but don't
worry about that just remember left
right left
all right left right left
okay
left
right
[Music]
left that is a fun death slide
oh
foreign
oh hi Timmy how are you doing
how you doing buddy hey what's up buddy
hey man you don't look so good uh hi
Timmy hey man how you been look I'm
really sorry about before in the man in
the park one when I ate you you see
Grandpa and I Come From Another
Dimension where humans are a natural
source of food let me try to explain
this is the international Parkside trash
candy realm it connects all the
interdimensional slides Harold sabotaged
the realm that's how Grandpa and I ended
up in your Park and now he's trapped me
in here while he carries out his evil
plan the only officer prepare the realm
using the secret code on a special blue
page oh gee golly you brought the page
this will save us let me see okay
okay the page says the end of the number
of blue slides you see in this room into
the computer that's easy enough I was
expecting a misplay puzzle don't screw
it up
um
I see three so far
I don't think that there's another blue
one lurking up there
I think it's three
why do you guys have computers
three
I said it I restored order to thrash
candy realm and saved
[Music]
what oh
yippee
ah no candy
all right
huh
if you're reading this the park has been
saved Harold's been defeated and Timmy
and I are back home with Mr Whiskers we
adopted him and are teaching him that
puns are really bad and say a lot about
a person who uses them because of your
persistence you have restored order and
made it possible for all of us to live
please take the personal eating candy
burgers okay as the hairy moldy green
gritty feeling chocolate melted under
the warm golden rays of the sun you
think to yourself park trash candy never
tasted so good
[Music]
you smile as you leave to go home you
stop by the drugstore for your favorite
menthol cigarettes and the cashier asks
how about some eye drops my friend your
eyes are looking a little red
all right well that was some GL I you
know I never knew I needed it till this
moment so anyway that's it for three
scary games oh thank you everybody so
much for watching uh if you saw any
weird animatronics at the beginning of
this uh video don't worry about that
that's that's something that's nothing
at all but also if you'd like to see
this go check it out
pretty proud of this the model was made
by emel Maco headed by voice by somebody
all right
thank you have a lovely day
[Music]
what
you really expect a jump scare here
you expect there to be just another jump
scare not everything has to end the same
way
why don't you go talk to the liar if you
want a few jump scares you are a little
late but the thing about time in the
internet and YouTube in general is that
you can go back to anything at any time
and check it out it exists it's there
waiting for you have you visited Yancey
in a while or boohoo made you think
about that now I bet you haven't even
found all the paths in in space have you
even found my secret ending we even
found the one I had in Heist you don't
even know about that do you
wow anyway
now just click the link just do the
thing just make a choice is yours really
someone said that something like that
anyway that's all
foreign